we are learning more about the victims
among them 10 year old javier lopez his
cousin described him as bubbly
he loved to dance and he was excited to
go swimming this summer
excuse me lilia luciano has been
speaking to heartbroken families as well
talking to some of the youngest
survivors lilia good morning to you
good morning tony you know i met an
eight-year-old boy yesterday who told me
that he was already used to the active
shooter drills at the school he knew
what to do but this time he knew it
wasn't a drill because he heard gunshots
he said that's when he his teachers and
his classmates went into hiding quietly
we hid behind desks and chairs
second grader timothy silva was in the
classroom right next to the one where
the shooting rampage unfolded we were
scared and the teacher started telling
us we can pray she said you can pray you
were all praying together
for 40 minutes his mother had no idea if
he was alive i started panicking crying
i was thinking that the shooter was
shooting everywhere that i was going to
go through one of the walls and
[Music]
shoot him timothy finally made it out
safe with his teacher and classmates
when i was happy i didn't get shot
but 19 of his schoolmates and two
teachers just a while away were shot and
killed hey guys ten-year-old eli garcia
was the second oldest of five daughters
she was very sweet her aunt sidi
arizmendi said she loved to dance and
also play sports she was very happy and
very outgoing
alexandria ania rubio's parents were at
school earlier that same day to
celebrate her she was awarded that
morning for being a good citizen
her mom said on facebook we had no idea
this was goodbye and these two fourth
great teachers are being praised as
heroes relatives briefed by police say
they died trying to protect their
students eva mireles had been a teacher
for 17 years
in a statement her daughter described
her as the half that makes me whole
irma garcia was just days away from
finishing up her 23rd year of teaching
she was a proud mom of four
it was something that
i would have never thought i'd had to
see here in your valley
coroner lalo diaz had the grim job of
walking through the crime scene which in
a small town like this one meant he knew
some of the victims
children that were
kids to people that i know we know each
other very well
it's just hard
as we've been reporting
parents were asked to give their dna to
identify the children i asked the
coroner about that he said mainly of
course it's for accuracy there was a lot
to go through and also the other reason
he said is because the parents could not
go into this kind of crime scene to
identify the children the priority was
to give answers to those parents who
were waiting for them he also told me he
hopes that today is the day when
families will receive the bodies of
their children if the medical examiner
in san antonio can finish the autopsies
oh lily just that phrase the bodies of
their children
it's the details they really get you and
those two teachers in the prime of their
life lilia thank you very much